Where do we go after Masters of the Universe:
Revelation Part 1 ended on the mother of all
cliffhangers?
What's a He-Man to do without a Sword of Power?
And what's going to happen next if we get
another season?
Let's dig in.
"Revelation Part 2" kicks off by briefly exploring
Teela's backstory.Teela's mother is revealed
to be none other than the Sorceress of Castle
Grayskull, who couldn't stay to raise her
daughter with Man-At-Arms because of her duty
as the new Sorceress.
She's clearly distraught over the thought
of not being with her daughter, but she paints
a magical protection charm on her which will
activate when she needs it the most.
Meanwhile, with Skeletor wielding the Sword
of Power, he has everything he's ever wanted
and begins turning the Eternian citizens into
a mindless zombie army.
It's this dire situation that forces Prince
Adam to try a radical solution: what happens
if he says the iconic words he uses to transform
without holding the sword?
He transforms into Savage He-Man, a mindless
brute who has all of the hero's strength and
none of his brains.
This is because the power is raw and unrefined
when it doesn't flow through the sword, so
he doesn't retain his own personality and
is just a being of pure rage ... He's basically
a blonde Hulk.
However, the only thing that gets through
to Savage He-Man is his father, King Randor.
In the time since Adam's death, the King spent
a lot of time wishing he'd told his son that
he loves him.
Now that he's alive again, the King finally
tells him that to his face.
It's those words that bring Adam out of his
Savage He-Man persona at Point Dread.
"I haven't told you I loved you.
And I haven't told you I'm proud of you."
After coming into power, one of Skeletor's
first acts of business is to make Evil-Lyn
the new sorceress, which she isn't exactly
pleased about because this keeps her locked
away in Grayskull.
Although Skeletor gives her access to the
entire universe, she's still not happy that
he keeps using her as a tool, rather than
as an ally.
It's difficult for Lyn, especially since she's
been with Skeletor most of her life.
But ultimately Skeletor's own short-sighted
goals make her realize that she can do so
much better.
He waxes lyrical about wanting to kill He-Man
once and for all, and it's here she comes
to the realization that Skeletor has no real
ambitions for the rest of the universe outside
of his eternal battle with Prince Adam.
"Then what?"
"What do you mean 'then what?'
I kill this version of He-Man too."
She even points out how dim-witted Skeletor
really is, as she seduces him to distract
the villain so she can take the Sword of Power
for herself.
Evil-Lyn takes the chance to transform into
an ethereal, omniscient warrior.
However, Lyn is forced to see all the universe
at once and makes the decision that she should
use her powers to snuff out every living thing.
One of the most surprising moments in the
series sees Skeletor surrender to the Eternian
forces, offering to team up with Prince Adam
to stop Evil-Lyn.
Hang on, did the lord of Snake Mountain actually
put the greater good ahead of his own desires
for once?
Now that's character development.
Still, the skull-faced baddie is obviously
aware that if Lyn wipes out the universe,
he'll have his own power stripped away from
him -- so it is more about self-preservation
rather than selflessness.
Unfortunately, even their team-up isn't enough
to simply put a stop to Lyn when she raises
the Subternian dead as her new army.
A sprawling battle between good and evil rages
on, while Adam and Skeletor try to keep Lyn
distracted long enough to get the Sword of
Power.
If there was any doubt about Adam's pure-heartedness,
it's dispelled here.
The hero puts his own eternal quarrel with
Skeletor aside, knowing that they need to
work together.
And once he gets his own powers back, he enhances
Skeletor back to his own hulking self too.
But there's a very specific reason why he
does this.
"But why?"
"Because I want you to know what saving the
universe feels like."
Teela is understandably reluctant to embrace
her own magical abilities -- largely because
she's still resentful for the fact that her
mother never tried to connect with her all
those years fighting for Grayskull.
That's on top of the fact that if she becomes
the new Sorceress, she'll be tied to the castle
and will never be allowed to leave.
But she tackles all of her concerns head-on,
even speaking with the ethereal ghost of the
Sorceress about how to make the mantle into
her own.
She refuses to do it the old isolated way,
explaining:
"Because holding on to the ones I love only
makes me stronger."
In short, she's relying on the close bond
she has with her friends to wield the Sorceress'
power in a new way, triumphantly saying,
“We have the power."
And sure, she gets into a flashy fight with
Lyn as the two show off their respective abilities
-- but Teela shows the villain the magnificence
of the universe, even convincing her to give
up her power.
Ultimately, Lyn just needs someone to get
through to her softer side.
He-Man and Skeletor should definitely take
a leaf out of Teela and Lyn's book because
they revert back to their typical fisticuffs
while the two sorcerers talk it out.
But that's all Skeletor wants -- to be, quote,
"locked in an eternal battle."
But He-Man isn't down with that.
"it's not about us."
It's a simple line, but he's essentially saying
that their ongoing fight means nothing in
the grand scheme of things.
He-Man hurls the villain into the outer reaches
of space, and all is right in the world — at
least for now.
Eternia rebuilds as it always does, while
Lyn puts herself into self-exile in a peaceful
location surrounded by the beauty of life.
But a final intriguing scene sees Skeletor
visit his former acolytes who now worship
an A.I. called Motherboard.
This malevolent new entity transforms into
a winged robotic giant, before plunging several
claws into Skeletor and filling him with a
techno-virus.
It doesn't look like it kills him, so this
isn't the last of Skeletor.
But the robot displays the holographic symbol
of Hordak, Skeletor's old mentor.
It looks like Eternia has caught the attention
of a vicious new enemy.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.